MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Grant.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh hey, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, I've been
using the gcloud command line
tool from the Cloud
SDK a lot recently,
and I'd like to get a bit
more productive with it.
Do you have any tips or tricks?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: I sure do.
I have six tricks up
my sleeve to help you
with your productivity
when using gcloud.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
Tell me more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you know, I'm trying to
learn the gcloud command line
tool a bit more.
And there are new flags
that I'm unfamiliar with,
like all the new
features of Cloud Run.
Is there a way I can quickly
learn these new features
and flags?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yes, there is.
So here's a fun one.
gcloud has an interactive mode
where you can see documentation
as you type.
To start interactive mode,
run gcloud beta interactive.
This will start a session
in your terminal providing
autocompletion and inline
documentation as you type.
So for example, Cloud Run
has a lot of feature flags
you can specify.
If you type gcloud
run deploy --,
you can go and toggle
through all the flags.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Yeah, that's --max-instances.
That's the one I
was looking for.
Cool.
All right.
Great.
Thank you for that tip.
For number two, here's
a different issue.
When I deploy to Cloud
Functions or to Cloud Run,
I keep getting the
same prompts in gcloud
when running those commands.
So like it asks me for my
location for my Cloud Run
service, or it
asks me to specify
I want to deploy to Cloud
Run Managed or to Kubernetes.
So I have to write these large
scripts with many command line
flags for this.
How do I avoid that?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, do you
know about gcloud configs?
MARTIN OMANDER: No, I don't.
GRANT TIMMERMAN:
Oh, let me show you.
So gcloud configs allow you
to save configuration options
so you don't need to
get prompted for them
and you don't need
to repeat them.
So the general syntax is
gcloud config set, and then
your property and value.
So for example, when
deploying to Cloud Run,
you could run the command
of gcloud run deploy myapp,
and then you provide
your --image.
But then you might notice,
oh, you get prompted, OK,
do you want Cloud
Run fully managed
and which region do you want?
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Right.
So let's go ahead
and cancel that.
Or you could go and
set your config.
So you can set your config
with gcloud config set
run/platform managed,
then maybe your run/region
to europe-west3.
So if I do that, then
it'll update the properties
and I can simply rerun
the previous command.
And you'll notice now,
I'm not prompted--
automatically just working.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, nice.
I like fewer prompts.
OK, cool.
For number three, sometimes, I
need to include the project ID
with a command.
I also switch between
projects often.
And sometimes, I use
the wrong project.
And I have actually,
in the past,
sometimes deployed code
to the wrong project.
My manager did not like that.
Is there an easier way
to manage the projects?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yeah, there is.
So I've faced this, too.
It's a little annoying
specifying your project name
everywhere.
And I don't really like
to mix up deploying
between different projects.
That's sort of scary.
But with gcloud, you can get
and set your current project.
So in your scripts,
you don't need
to hardcode your project ID.
So in the command line,
you can set the project
with gcloud config set project
and then your project name.
Once you have done
that, then that
will be your default project
with all the gcloud commands.
And you can also get
your current project
and store it in an
environment variable.
How do you do that?
Well, you can go and type--
you can go and type--
let's say you want your project.
Here's a little script
to set your project
inside this
environment variable.
Then you can use this
environment variable anywhere,
like when using gcloud.
So here's a little example.
When using gcloud build submit,
you can provide your tag
and you always
need your project.
And so it'll just
recognize that and work.
So I use this all the
time in my scripts
when deploying to Cloud Run.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, nice.
No more deploying code to
the wrong project for me.
So for number four,
I switch around
between a few
different projects,
and I sometimes forget which
projects have billing enabled.
Many Cloud Services
require billing
to be enabled before using them.
So how can I check that, Grant?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, that's
a good question, Martin.
So with gcloud, there's
a relatively new command
you can use to go
and check this.
You can run the following
gcloud beta billing command.
So after you run this,
you get your project.
You describe it.
And you'll get a Boolean
value of True or False.
And so this will
indicate if billing's
enabled for that project.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Now I can check if billing is
enabled for all my projects
without having to go to the web
browser and the Cloud Console
over there.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yep.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So for number five, when I've
deployed a private Cloud Run
service, I can't really
test it using curl.
If I try to curl it, I get the
response, error, forbidden.
How do I fix that?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yep.
So a Cloud Run service
that wasn't deployed
with --allow-unathenticated
is not
accessible with
unauthorized requests.
So for example,
we can go and try
curling a Cloud Run service,
and we'll see an error.
For example, like 403 forbidden.
Not anybody on the public web
can test our proprietary Cloud
Run service.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's
what I'm getting, yep.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yep.
But that's really very
difficult to test.
It's great that
we have security,
but we want to be
able to test locally.
So by adding our HTTP auth
bearer token when curling,
we can go and fix this issue.
And so here, we'll just provide
a header with our authorization
token from gcloud.
And you can see, Heyo, Martin!
MARTIN OMANDER: It works.
Nice.
I'll use that, for sure.
So but, Grant, so this
worked, but whose access level
was used now for this command?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: That's
a really great question.
So this command uses
the same authorization
as the person who
logged into that machine
with gcloud auth login.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, nice.
All right.
For number six, sometimes
when using Google Cloud,
I'm supposed to use a project
number rather than a project
ID.
This is, for example, when
I'm using service accounts
or creating service accounts.
Is there a way to get
that project number
if I have the project ID?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, yeah.
So well, with a little
bit of gcloud-fu,
you can go and get one
value from the other.
So with this little command--
I use this all the time--
you can go and get
your project number
if you have your project ID.
So what it does
in the background
is it lists your projects
and gets your project ID
and then formats it
just for that number.
So you might use this with
different credentials,
or especially like
with Cloud Storage.
And likewise, let's say you
have that project number,
but you want to get your ID.
And so you can do the reverse.
And you can go
list your projects
and get that project ID.
And there, you get
your project ID.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Thanks for showing me these six
incredibly useful tips, Grant.
I didn't know you can
do all of that stuff
from the command line.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, you're
quite welcome, Martin.
I keep discovering new features
and new tips to myself.
I guess you learn
something new every day
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yes.
I've learned six
new things today.
Thank you, everyone,
for watching.
We hope you found
these tips useful.
And please enter any
questions or comments below.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]